you get to be the same while I'm stuck
here fighting these walls all by myself
a thousand and one directed by AV
Rockwell won the grand jury prize in the
festival's U.S dramatic competition it's
the story of a young single mother
struggling to raise her son in poverty
it's sort of a very gritty realistic
kitchen sink Style movie for three
quarters of its running time and then
you get to the ending and there is just
something that like it's like you're
being like kicked in the guts by a horse
by The Twist that comes Scrapper a
British coming-of-age film won the world
Cinema dramatic competition
sides on the winners and how do they do
it
nigerian-american filmmaker funa maduka
was on the jury that picked Scrapper it
was really really hard we had 12 films
from around the world and you know as a
jury we're all coming with our different
experiences Chilean filmmaker Maite
alberti's documentary The Eternal memory
carried away the jury best world Cinema
documentary prize which is a love story
you know an Alzheimer's love story but
in it in this love story it unpacks a
really important political history of
Chile and pinochet's crimes however the
politics is subtext of the storytelling
and I think that's always the best
storytelling the process of judging
films can be emotionally intense I mean
there were no fist fights but you know
but we but we definitely had some
passionate words about the meaning of
film and what films what films need the
award what films don't what film
problems you know what rubric do you use
to award Sundance baby audiences get to
vote on their favorites too Mr sloth
chernoth 20 days in mariopal won the
audience Award for best Cinema
documentary
and sometimes a small movie from a small
country can really stand out
is slow for which she won a directing
award I spoke with her after the award
ceremony and she said you don't know
what this has done for Lithuanian film
and I said you don't know what you've
done for Lithuanian film sorry
altogether 32 prizes were awarded at
Sundance
and so for 2023's biggest and most
influential independent film festival
that's a wrap Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera
Park City Utah